mario tim clark uci mais si martine
buvette et fils à ti ont noté un des
effets relaxants de misery qui veut
tirer dessus la digue avec rami chef de
file d'un groupe de juifs ultra
orthodoxe le rabbin guette chez le
responsable des lieux saints de la
vieille ville et en particulier du mur
occidental
ce mur a rappelé aussi le mur des
lamentations est un vestige du temple de
salomon
un symbole sacré pour les juifs
religieux du monde entier
le lieu suprême de la prière
là
jour et nuit le long ce mur à
l'intérieur comme à l'extérieur les
hommes pris leur dieu et étudient la
torah parfois comme aujourd'hui le
rabbin guedj passe dans la partie
musulmane de la ville
[Musique]
mais c'est pas commémorative ses dents
ont été assassinés tout récemment je
n'en ai pas gardé comme chaque fois
qu'ils pénètrent dans ce secteur une
patrouille de l'armée va l'escorté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
depuis 1967 les juifs rachète des
maisons dans cette partie de la vieille
ville où vivent presque uniquement des
palestiniens le rabbin parle d'une
présence juive dans la ville arabe
d'autres dénoncent la provocation les
religieux ont installé aussi
progressivement quelques yeshiva des
écoles où les hommes étudie les
écritures saintes ici chez le rabbin
avis nerfs l'essentiel des recherches et
des réflexions concerne la
reconstruction du temple de salomon
aujourd'hui un soldat israélien vient de
recevoir un coup de couteau
un incident comme il s'en produit
régulièrement presque chaque semaine
difficile de parler de cohabitation
harmonieuse
même s'il s'agit toujours d'actes commis
par des fanatiques
d'un côté comme de l'autre les deux
quartiers sont séparés par des grilles
fermées la nuit est continuellement
gardés par des militaires
une frontière dans la ville l'image
d'une cohabitation placée sous le signe
de la sécurité de la méfiance
tout le monde ici touristes ou habitants
passent et repassent habitués à ce
dispositif
le rabbin retrouve ce qu'il appelle son
royaume l'esplanade du mur c'est là que
son escorte va le laisser
on exige que soient escortées c'est pour
moi qu'il est désiré m'impose du fait
que de temps en temps un peu de grabuge
dans ma vieille ville est quelqu'un
puisse tirer un poignard ou jeter une
pierre aux mêmes heures chose on préfère
que ce soit couvert c'est pas moi qui le
désirent ça me gêne d'ailleurs sinon il
ya une cohabitation qui a été fait
partout il ya des faux dans l'est
l'autre aussi à défaut nous tenons à ce
qu'il y ait un peu de grabuge
c'est dans son bureau et la salle de
cours qui surplombe l'esplanade du mur
que le rabbin guesh travail et enseignes
20 heures sur 24 des fonctions
religieuses et administratives qui font
de lui un personnage important est
exposée je suis sur le qui vive
je n'ai pas toujours le doigt sur la
gâchette mais je suis toujours prêt
c'est l'espagne ont paradé si vous aussi
vous voulez la paix soyez prêts pour le
combat
c'est votre adage le suivant 7 roth
ça ne veut rien dire en soi ce que nous
venons pas la paix oise voulons tous
vivre ensemble dans l'amour dans la
fraternité c'est tous dieu nous a créés
deux fois par semaine comme ce matin les
familles juives viennent célébrer la bar
mitzvah au pied du mur
cette cérémonie l'équivalent la connaît
bien chez les chrétiens marque le
passage à l'âge adulte pour les garçons
13 ans cette famille de colons installés
à hébron a choisi jérusalem plutôt que
la synagogue de sa ville
suivant les traditions l'enceinte
principale du mur n'est accessible
qu'aux hommes les femmes ont leur coin
de prières à l'autre bout de l'esplanade
selon la tradition toujours les hommes
seuls étudie et cela commence dès le
plus jeune âge dans cette yeshiva les
enfants aussi sept ou huit ans ils
n'étudient pas les maths ou l'histoire
seulement la torah
après 1967 le quartier juif a été
entièrement rénové de riches européens
ou américains
comme cet homme natif charles ont acheté
des maisons dans la vieille ville
réalisant enfin leur rêve de venir vivre
sur la terre promise
lui est un homme d'affaires sa femme qui
prépare aujourd'hui le pain du shabbat
est l'auteur de fameux livre de cuisine
ils vivent depuis dix ans à jérusalem je
ressentais ce pays est un pige juifs
nous avons su petit morceau de terre les
arabes peuvent aller partout ils veulent
dans le monde
nous sommes à porte dans la tempête pour
les juifs et originaire de russie en
ethiopie par exemple qui viennent ici
car ils ne peuvent aller nulle part
ailleurs
moi je suis venu car j'ai senti que
cette terre nous appartenait
spécialement dans la ville où je vis
juste en face du mur des lamentations
c'est très particulier
quand je suis arrivé ici je n'étais pas
religieux je suis devenu il ya dix ans
environ
mais ça c'est une autre la prière et les
études rythme aujourd'hui la journée de
cet homme d'affaires qui a choisi aussi
de consacrer une partie de ses
ressources à la construction d'une école
talmudique en face de chez lui
oh
depuis 20 ans le rabbin guedj dirige les
travaux à la recherche des fondations
des temples de david et salomon dans le
prolongement du mur occidental
environ 500 m de souterrains ont déjà
été dégagés creusé à mende homme
découvrant des pierres millénaires dans
une salle du souterrain
on a placé la maquette du deuxième
temple décrite dans le texte du prophète
isaïe
arriver bientôt une époque où nous
trouvons le reconstruire preuve les
prophéties et à l'avènement de
d'une machine à l'autre chanteur tels
que nous entendons si vous voulez et
reconstruira ça veut dire qu'il va
falloir
mais un certain nombre d'autres non non
c'est pas à nous de faire ça tout ce que
nous voulons tous nos actions sont des
actions divine nos écrits dans un
caisson ésotérique aussi nous savons
qu'il y aura un tremblement de terre qui
débarrassent un je vous avais eu tout ce
qui n'est pas juste alors le terrain est
à nouveau au dessus des souterrains la
ville arabe la via dolorosa l'esplanade
des mosquées
selon nos croyances
nous sommes le peuple élu parmi les bugs
mais ça ne nous attendait de voir
arriver des avoirs et l'interdiction de
ce qu'on appelle un faux listings en
scène intérieure plus sacrées du monde
et jérusalem est la plus sacrée de la
terre d'israël et le lieu du temple le
plus sacré encore de jérusalem et c'est
dans ce lieu là que nous pourrions non
pas seulement pour le peuple d'israël
mais pour tout le peuple du monde
je suis passé par ici des dizaines de
milliers de fois mais sa voix que je
passerais 600 ému et musulmans nous nous
c'est je le vois le passage de madère de
les ailleurs de mayroy et j'espère voir
bientôt ce duel il machir rancière
celles et ceux qui nous sommes nous
mêmes le père et le père du monde
c'est ici que va être créé la paix
mondiale qui sont indécis qui s'étirait
sur le monde hier il est une heure du
matin comme chaque nuit le rabbin gay tu
vas donner son cours de kabal se peut
son confort et ses dr chiche
donc tu le voulais la cabane c'est le
stade le plus élevé de l'étude et dans
l'interprétation des textes divin
réservé à une élite ses élèves sont
ingénieurs architectes ou dentistes
comme ce français installé depuis cinq
ans à jérusalem jérusalem c'est un sens
pour vous cette ville c'est pour moi le
sens absolu dans mon existence
aujourd'hui nous vivons nous projetons
tout tout tout tout notre volonté
dangereuses les je comprends pas ce que
ça veut dire
jérusalem est la ville que dieu a choisi
comme résidence matériel dans ce monde
aucune autre place au monde ne peut
repasser le relais et pendant 2000 ans
le legs motif que tous les juifs données
répéter à chaque fête l'année prochaine
à jérusalem est
ouais
bah
sa mère
à l'été
ah mais à des rats
[Musique]
voici le centre du monde c'est ici que
tout a commencé et que tout doit finir
sur la pierre mythique du temple de
jérusalem est là où selon la légende se
rassemblent les âmes qui attendent la
fin des temps
c'est le troisième lieu saint de l'islam
après la mecque et médine
les sabots d'al bouraq le cheval du
prophète ont frappé la roche avant de
bondir vers le ciel y rencontrer dieu
lors du voyage de mohamed à jérusalem
[Musique]
la ville seront bienvenus
le home il
moss gibbs profond
on saura bien dit
là il a
selon la tradition musulmane
une seule prière récitée dans ces
mosquées ou sur les 12 hectares de
l'esplanade vos cinq sens prières
prononcées ailleurs les habitants du
quartier musulman de la vieille ville
vend donc plusieurs fois par semaine sur
leurs lieux saints dont ils se
considèrent comme les gardiens
[Musique]
ma fais assez lit par exemple il ne rate
pas une occasion d'expliquer aux
militants nationalistes juifs installés
près de chez lui qu'il ne sont pas les
bienvenus moi je suis né ici et vous aux
états unis d'amérique
je suis né dans ce quartier je suis
heureux c'est la mi temps un israélien
c'est le droit de vivre ici librement
pensez vous qu'il devait me demander la
permission de vivre ici vous n'êtes pas
un juif vous n'appartenez pas israël
jérusalem mais cher comme aux juifs et
aux chrétiens
vous n'avez rien à faire ici vous êtes
américains je suis palestinien
je suis juive vous êtes juif américain
non je suis juif qu'elle passe quand
vous avez juif je suis un juif et l'état
des juifs c'est israël vous ne pouvez
pas dire je suis arabe décidées dont
j'ai des droits plus que vous je suis
descendant d'abraham mais qui a commencé
la guerre qui a commencé les guerres
c'est nous c'est vous en 67 c'est vous
qui avait commencé la guerre excusez moi
s'il vous plaît étudié l'histoire vous
falsifier les faits je ne suis pas un
historien je le fais tu es que j'habite
à jérusalem je vis aussi à jérusalem en
ce moment on ne devait pas me rejeter
mais m'accepter je vous accepte mais
n'essayez pas de me tuer quoi n'essayez
pas de me tuer nous pouvons vivre en
voisin mais n'essayez pas de me tuer
c'est ce que vous tentez de faire il n'y
a pas de terroristes parmi les juifs une
fois il ya eu un réseau clandestin pour
défendre les juifs parce que le
gouvernement ne le faisait pas on l eau
pierre et donnez-nous vos fusils
prenez nos pierres et donnez-nous vos
fusils oui nafez n'a pas besoin de
montrer sa carte d'identité aux
policiers israéliens qui garde l'entrée
de l'esplanade
ils le connaissent il
un régulièrement brillé
nous sommes sous le dôme noir de la
mosquée al aqsa construit en 638 par le
khalife walid ben abd al malik
il y avait ici des trésors d'art
islamique réalisé il ya 900 ans
ce que vous voyez a été reconstituée
après l incendie de 1969 un juif
australiens avaient mis le feu à la
mosquée tout a brûlé
je me souviens ce jour là j'ai étudié à
l'école coranique
je me suis précipité pour aider tous
ceux qui tentaient d'éteindre le feu
il y avait des flammes partout mais
aussi dans nos coeurs nous avons juré de
tout reconstruire comme avant
cette partie est en cours de
reconstitution le travail est bien
entendu effectué entièrement à la main
par des artisans nous mettons six mois
pour réaliser un seul vitrail
il est impossible de savoir quand tout
sera prêt une école coranique occupent
les bâtiments de la partie nord de
l'esplanade et tous ceux qui ont passé
ici leur enfance se souviennent
d'instants magiques dans ces endroits où
le profane devient sacré quand j'étais
au lycée je venais faire mes devoirs ici
ou réfléchir là au sud-est du dôme du
rocher
c'est un endroit tranquille je pouvais
me parler à moi même méditer tout
jérusalem attend en mars prochain
la fin de la restauration du dôme du
rocher qui pour la première fois depuis
des siècles sera vraiment doré la
couverture en aluminium posée au début
des années 60 est remplacé par des
feuilles de cuivre plaqué or
les travaux financés par le roi hussein
de jordanie sont réalisés par une
entreprise irlandaise estime djaouad
l'architecte palestinien responsable des
travaux espère que la mosquée sera à
l'abri des intempéries pendant des
décennies mais son principal souci est
d'ailleurs il craint une opération
d'extrémistes juifs à la recherche de
souterrains cacher certains d'entre eux
croient peut-être que les trésors du
temple de salomon sont enterrés quelque
part en dessous des mosquées et vous
croyez que c'est possible je ne le pense
pas mais vous ne pouvez pour rechercher
quelque chose que vous convoitez
justifier la destruction de tout ce
qu'il ya autour
injustifiable les dirigeants musulmans
suivent donc avec une extrême attention
tout ce qui se passe quelques dizaines
de mètres plus bas aux alentours du mur
des lamentations
il est 11h souleymane jabbari le mufti
le chef spirituel des musulmans de
terre-sainte dirige la seconde prière de
la journée dans la mosquée du dôme du
rocher prière silencieuse ponctuée par
le verset allahu akbar dieu est grand
les fidèles se prosternent dans la
direction de la mecque
les palestiniens revendiquent ces lieux
saints qu'il considère comme le joyau de
leur futur état
mais les jordaniens ne renoncent pas à
leurs droits historiques sur les
mosquées les muftis de jérusalem est
toujours nommés par le roi hussein de
jordanie
le cheikh souleymane jabbari est donc
très prudents lorsqu'ils évoquent
l'avenir ni condamne avant tout
l'installation de militants juifs parmi
les dix-huit mille habitants du quartier
musulman mais ne parle surtout pas du
statut futur des mosquées pour que la
stabilité reviennent il faut deux états
côte à côte un état juif et un état
palestinien si les colons israéliens
renforcent l'hostilité et constituent un
danger
cette rue doit être sous contrôle
palestinien pour qu'il y ait un accord
n'a fait zasseli habite avec ses parents
et ses deux fils au 13 rue lillois d' un
cauchemar pour le facteur dix sept
familles comptant chacune au moins huit
dix personnes y résident dans un
incroyable dédale de couloirs et
d'escaliers la famille possède depuis
des générations trois minuscules pièces
auxquelles elle n'a aucune intention de
renoncer
les pousses de la fed n'a pas supporté
ce genre de vie et le couple est en
instance de divorce
car on ne déménage pas lorsque l'on
habite à mi chemin entre le saint
sépulcre est le centre du monde
on y attend une paix qui à jérusalem
passerait nécessairement par un partage
dans le respect des droits et des
croyances de toutes les communautés
oui nous proposons une jérusalem unifiée
puisque la ville est chère au coeur des
juifs et des musulmans
jérusalem-est devrait être la capitale
de l'état palestinien l'ouest étant la
capitale d'israël
il y aurait donc deux municipalités
séparés mais supervisé par un conseil
d'administration commun
[Musique]
ce vendredi des dizaines de milliers de
fidèles répondent à l'appel du muet jean
depuis la signature de l'accord entre
israël et l'olp et le 13 septembre la
police a considérablement assoupli ses
règlements et de nombreux musulmans sont
autorisés à venir de gaza et de
cisjordanie en dépit du bouclage des
territoires occupés
les prières ici sont dit avec une
ferveur particulière
selon la tradition ses 200 voyages
nocturnes à jérusalem que le prophète
mohamed a rapporté comme cadeau divin
les cinq prières quotidiennes qui
constitue pour le musulman
l'entrée en la présence divine
oh
[Musique]
oa
[Applaudissements]
quand jésus à projets de la ville qu'il
a perçus il perd à suresnes
il disait si toi aussi tu avais su en ce
jour comment trouver la paix mais là
cela a été caché à tes yeux
oui pour toi des joueurs vont venir ou
tes ennemis et aviron contre toi
d'élevage de sièges qu'ils conserveront
et essaieront de tout pas l'intégration
toi et tes enfants au milieu de toi et
ils ne laisseront pas en toi pierre sur
pierre
parce que tout n'a pas reconnu le temps
où tu as tes visites et c'est la
situation de jérusalem aujourd'hui j'ai
décrite dans ce texte
si la situation de jérusalem en tout
temps ce mystère de jésus dieu a choisi
cette ville est les hommes
or il ya toujours du refus dans
l'attitude des ans même dans leur foi
aujourd'hui il ya toutes les croyances
il ya les trois grandes religions toute
l'oise en croit en dieu et avec cela
tous tous les foyers on n'arrive pas à
accueillir dans leur foi
le frère qui appartient une fois
différent
à jérusalem même les chrétiens
d'ethiopie vaiete psalmodie sans relâche
dans une chapelle voisine du saint
sépulcre pour les descendants abyssinien
de la reine de saba aussi le tombeau du
christ et centre de gravité de leur foi
l e
ah ah
les chants arméniens eux en ce lieu
depuis 1600 en la basilique était
byzantine alors et les croisés n'étaient
pas encore venus déloger les infidèles
il ne reste que quatre mille arméniens à
jérusalem mais ils rendent un hommage
constant au sacrifice qui fonde la
religion chrétienne
et j
pour michel sabbah le patriarche latin
de terre sainte il n'est pas de lieu
plus sacré que cette dalle qui dans sa
croyance à enfermer le corps supplicié
voilà près de deux mille ans de ce juif
pas comme les autres qu'on appelait
jésus de nazareth
les pèlerins qui se pressent dans la
pénombre enveloppante du saint sépulcre
ne savent pas la plupart du temps qu'à
l'arrière du tombeau aussi ils peuvent
toucher lapierre tant vénéré un prêtre
copte chrétiens d'égypte montent la
garde
[Applaudissements]
les deux dernières stations du calvaire
de la fameuse via dolorosa sont aussi
enfermé dans la basilique
ici une religieuse vénère le rocher où
était planté les croix des voleurs et
autres agitateurs subversif de la
palestine romaine de l'époque sous
l'oeil de la gardienne des lieux
une religieuse orthodoxes
[Musique]
les musulmans respectent
le saint sépulcre met à profit si jésus
compte en fait non pas confie studieux
mais ils ont la vénération pour le saint
sépulcre les juifs me respecte
je suis pour le moment le peuple suit
france entre ce pacte
marc étienne hubert
les juifs religieux extrémistes
c'est à 50 mètres de là que le calife
omar à prier allah quand son arme et
prosélyte est entré dans jérusalem en
681 pas question pour lui de profaner le
tombeau du christ en y entrant avec ses
soldats aujourd'hui en revanche des
israélites d'extrémistes ont investi le
spi saint jean à quelques pas seulement
du saint sépulcre les chrétiens quittent
jérusalem on quittait g20 ceux qui
restent sont entre eux peuvent il ya 40
ans avant le commencement de tous ces
troubles
il y avait trente mille chrétiens sont
deux cent mille habitants à jérusalem
aujourd'hui il y a dix mille six cent
mille le quartier chrétien commence
porte de jaffa hills à souda comptable
de son état et chef d'une famille
catholique très fervent tu va nous
servir de guide
seules activités du lieu le business
touristique aux religieux même des
soldats israéliens traverse la zone
arabe par ici pour aller prier au mur
des lamentations via le souk
ce quartier est d'ailleurs arabe avant
d'être chrétien ou musulman c'est la
ville palestinienne de ses frontières
comment aussi comment sont ces décès
jour levé ville a espéré rend trois
places
free mine san jose pour le quartier juif
et moyse hospitalier pour les
palestiniens priés de rester chez eux
parfois la tension peut empoisonner
l'atmosphère entre arabes et israéliens
même si toutes les apparences commercial
milite pour l'oecuménisme
on vend beaucoup d'hébreu en secteur
arabe mais chaque communauté sur le
qui-vive vigilante à l'extrême après
l'attentât à l'armé blanche contre un
soldat israélien deux jours plus tôt en
lisière du quartier juifs chrétiens et
musulmans sont inquiets ils ont circulé
dans la rue ils ont frappé ils ont 4 et
de marchandises
j'aimerais qu'ils sa légendaire hamas
non les juifs fanatiques d un commando
de manifestations juifs à l'éthique soir
7 heures 6 heures 17 heures ils veulent
pas des halles enrichi
parfois les pressions ou les
provocations de certains juifs ultra
religieux ont raison de la détermination
palestinienne mais les églises
orientales veille parce que la présence
chrétienne ne soit pas battu en brèche
déjà les chrétiens n'ont que deux
émigrés le patriarche de l'église
grecque catholique veut arrêter
l'hémorragie sans présent compter tient
dans cette ville sainte depuis 2000 ans
d'une manière ininterrompue qu'on
chrétiens comparables sont présents dans
cette ville sainte et djiboutiens depuis
à peu près 5000 ont donc cela est un
doigt et une base de doit absolument
indiscutable pour le droit des chrétiens
sur jérusalem
donc je dirais tout simplement nous
avons droit comme les juifs endroits
comme les musulmans en droit et nous
sommes par aucune manière en aucune
manière prêt à abdiquer cette présence
chrétienne à jérusalem et dans les
terrains vagues on s'est remis dans la
famille soudas les parents et leurs
quatre filles dont une étudier
actuellement aux usa
tout le monde est soudé dans l'amour de
jérusalem et le processus de paix en
marche conforte l'espoir à la world et à
part des si le monde est encore
jérusalem et son coeur sors tu enlèves
vivent dans la vieille ville c'est vivre
à côté du coeur et à jérusalem pour moi
jésus est né sais que j'y resterai
jusqu'à ma dernière heure je suis très
heureuse ici à jérusalem
bien sûr nous avons des problèmes comme
dans tous les pays du monde mais petit à
petit si dieu le veut nous aurons la
paix
souvent à table issa évoque ses frères
et soeurs ses cousins dispersés aux
quatre coins du monde
son souhait que la paix leur permettent
de revenir dans une jérusalem également
capitale de la palestine lui même qui se
réclament désormais de l'ol paie est un
farouche militant du dialogue en tant
que membres de ma communauté comme
palestiniens chrétiens à l'ouest j'ai
fait de mon mieux pour favoriser la
compréhension entre juifs avaient la
situation actuellement à jérusalem c'est
comme une naissance
on souffle il y a des problèmes mais le
résultat est comme un nouvel enfant baby
je suis sûr que la pièce force
[Musique]
allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la ferveur de la famille soudaine n'est
pas exceptionnel à jérusalem les
palestiniens chrétiens qui sont restés
malgré les difficultés économiques et
les rigueurs de l'intifada reste autant
par amour de leur vieux murs favori que
parfois religieuse à jérusalem
une majorité de moder et chrétiens
attend que ce haut lieu des trois
religions monothéistes demeure
accessible aux pèlerins du monde et
deviennent également la capitale des
deux peuples qui y coexistent
[Musique]